and that's one of the reasons why such a
successful leader and now while he will
not be denominating you know as well as
I do that Mike Bloomberg is one of those
relentless people here our economy he
never stops he never gives up he's
always working it's already talking
about going back to work Chiqui brahmins
and power
paddy Harris and so many many others
Robin completely crazy it's so many many
more then I had this conversation in the
back and I thought about society you
should do this when I was man
Philadelphia actually recognized without
[Applause]
continue
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
23
you know and he started we had the
slogan wrong this should be Mike likes
you not sure what you say other than
thank you to everybody here's tried to
make a difference and maybe another Mike
you really have been amazing
we're already hiding right here hiding
in plain sight these past few months
have been some of the most inspiring
certainly in my life and I hope in yours
in just 100 days I have been to 73
cities in 27 states all across the
country from Detroit Michigan down to
Jackson Mississippi and every place I
when I listen to Americans of every age
in every race and every ethnicity and
every religion and every identity and
orientation and I heard about their
hopes and their dreams and their fears
and their struggles and those type of
conversations just affirm my faith in
the work that our team was doing to
defeat drunk
bring our country back together and get
things done for the American people
now today I want to say how grateful I
am to everyone who has been a part of
our team and I want to thank you all
from the bottom of my heart for your
support your work and your votes and I'm
just telling you the American public
should be saying thank you didn't you as
well
you really made history you really did
[Applause]
we did in such a short period of time to
go back
we started at 1% in the polls but
yesterday thanks to you
nearly 2 million Americans cast their
votes for our campaign this really is
the best most creative most hardworking
campaign team ever assembled and I have
to say there is no doubt in my mind we
would we would have beaten Donald Trump
in November
knows that drama
he's been staying stiff of us and for
good reason because every time he hit us
we hit back twice as hard and unlike his
jabs our punches pack the truth now look
today I am clear tied by our overriding
objective and that is victory in
November campaign but victory for our
country would president to defeat Donald
Trump and today I am leaving the race
for the same reason to defeat Donald
Trump because say and we would make it
more difficult to achieve that goal I've
always believed that the days should
inform our decisions that's so I ran my
business and foundation it's the way we
were in City Hall in fact our campaign
slogan was in god we trust' everyone
else bring data yesterday's results the
delegate math had become virtually
impossible in a viable path the
nomination just no longer existed and I
will not be our party's nominee but I
will not walk away from the most
important political fight of my life and
I hope you will walk away
either
I've always believed I've always
believed that the feeding down the front
starts with uniting behind the candidate
before the best shot to do it and if the
yesterday's vote is clear that candidate
is my friend and a great ofamerican Joe
Biden I know his decency his honesty his
commitment to the issues that are so
important to our country including gun
safety health care climate change and
good jobs and I've had a chance to work
with Joe on those issues over the years
especially when he was vice president he
fought for working people his whole life
and I'm glad to say I endorsed Joe Biden
and I hope you will join me in working
[Applause]
it is enormous understatement to say
that I'm immensely proud of the campaign
that we're in and the issues we raised
in the Sweeting achievable plans we
proposed and that includes our Greenwood
initiative to write to start to fight
racial inequality and make the promise
of equal opportunity real for the black
communities that have been doing
centuries of exploitation and
discrimination that work I've always
thought is fundamental to the future of
our country
and it's the more perfect union and each
generation is called to build this
afternoon I want you to all know that I
am grateful to everyone who supported us
to everyone on our campaign headquarters
near New York the work that you did
every day late at nights early mornings
and weekends and holidays was really
just amazing and to our incredible staff
and volunteers of the states you knocked
on more than two million doors and had
more than 12 million conversations with
voters and to the traveling
and for the traveling team to advance
the press you made great events look
easy you made them look flawless
exciting and energizing you were the
road warriors no one outwork all of you
and that's for sure I'm very proud and
you should be too because you devoted
your days and nights doing the most
important job in America beating Donald
Trump and working to reclaim our values
and rebuild our country
so before I close I just want to thank
our campaigns amazing coaches who are
among America's most respected and
effective leaders Steve Benjamin
Stephanie Murphy
Manny Diaz Gina Raimondo Bobby Rush
Stephanie Rollins break Antonio Vega
Rosa and of course the incomparable
Marco mutters
[Applause]
and member of Congress and everyone else
who believes in us who we endorsed Park
Tennessee and who worked hard to unite
voters around your vision this morning I
called about 75 of them just to say
thank you and this may be the 75 best
conversations I've ever had they really
believe and they were as proud today if
they didn't do us this as they worded it
before when before we work we live for
the voters your support and your trust
meant the world to me and to them and I
look forward to working with all of you
in the months and years ahead you know
I've been doing this for a long time and
every day gets better am I can tell you
today I'm sorry we didn't win but it's
still the best day of my life and
tomorrow is gonna be even better
I'm planning to do when I hope that a
desk
I also have effect a few people with his
spectacular job pulling this whole team
together and managing the campaign and
always giving me honest advice even when
I didn't want it
I can pay off with a clear simple
promise Mike will get it done and today
I kind of promise you I'm gonna keep
working on it and I hope you will too
and I'm gonna tell you my daughters and
Diana and all of my friends are
committed to doing the same thing
because as we all know it means pets and
common-sense gun-safety laws that say
like protecting our communities and
climate change
[Applause]
it means making sure that every child
can attend a great public school no
matter what zip code they live in it
means fighting against discrimination in
equality wherever they exist and it
means protecting a woman's right to
choose that's it
let me just say this I have never
believed in doing anything halfway when
I believe in something I work like crazy
and it's fight like hell to achieve I
know what this race would be all about
I knew we didn't have much of a chance
but we did it anyways and I'm just
amazed at how many people have stood
with me shoulder to shoulder
working and fighting every step of the
way I know you didn't do it for me you
did it for our country for America
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's all I could ever ask for
and being part of this campaign is more
than a young boy who memorized the
midnight ride of Paul Revere Audrina
today I believe that our great nation
still sees that light in the Old North
Church Thailand the light of freedom the
light of Liberty and quite a bit quality
from the torch of the Statue of Liberty
and inspires the world with our values
and our ideals no wall can block out
that way and we will not allow any
president to dim that light seeing that
light shining in the faces of millions
of Americans in every person who was
part of our campaign and everyone from
every political party who believes that
we must begin bringing our country back
together
and putting the United back in the
United States of America
and so today
Hey our campaign today for the present
presidency ends but our campaign for a
better America a stronger America a more
just in America a more equal America and
what United in America continues and
together we will get it done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here is more contagious than the virus
itself and and today actually I did the
ascent on purpose of chrono virus
because I just wanted to make a
statement telling to the people that
actually there is this huge paranoia
there is this fear circulating and the
problem is a fear is more contagious
than the virus itself
I know you from Jersey to get returned
to the pizza
the video jungle debuggable soon as
demented Julie Estes to villain in
sativa via emotion card with Vanguard in
ER the sport car on street superior
[Music]